Jennifer congratulations Rachel Stern
from Entertainment Tonight thank you
Rachel how did it feel to share this
moment with Giancarlo Esposito on stage
oh cool I love that coming up going up
with someone yeah I mean I yeah I've
never done that before where you get to
come up together yeah and I um I usually
don't know how I'm going to get up the
stairs and um so yeah no that was
amazing yeah and and I love him and he's
so charismatic and and uh
yeah I mean I mean what a gift what a
gift that I get to share a moment with
an actor that I really enjoy and respect
and you said in your speech it's anyone
who's given up hope it gives inspiration
it's not over until you're dead how
alive do you feel right now I feel so
alive you know you know I mean you go
through your life and you sort of you
just assume you're used to it going a
certain way and you just take on that
whatever that baggage is that it's never
going to change and Mike White who I
didn't get to you know I've thanked him
in many other things but Mike White sort
of changed it all HBO changed it all it
just my life was changed overnight and
um I I could not be more grateful and
that's for sure you know
truly uh the surprise of a lifetime
could you ever imagine you'd be sweeping
Awards
Awards
oh
Glenn I'm watching I mean I'm not no
this was so so this is so nice and look
I mean I'm not saying you know you have
to
you know it all has to be about winning
Awards to for happiness or whatever but
to get another shot
and you know have you know get to play a
role like Tanya in White Lotus that I
could never have ever foreseen that
moment
uh happening to me you know I just I
could never have seen that and and
thought that could possibly happen and
um
and um again I can't talk about enough
about how grateful I am for
all these people that you know
rallied and got me uh you know signed
off on me for White Lotus you know I I
think you know I might have
I don't know
I don't know if there was people that
didn't want me but there was enough that
did I got in there at the last second
whatever it was I don't know someone
died or something and I got in and I'm
so happy not that they died but that I
got in
you know you know what I mean I promise
you we all want Jennifer Coolidge oh hey
thanks a lot thank you thank you I'm
thrilled tonight
I mean look I don't even know what I'm
gonna do tonight now
I mean sky's the limit
thank you thank you
anything else Jennifer congratulations
hey hi a lot of talk that you are just
like your character in White Lotus
um
yeah I mean uh
I think I've been pretty clueless for a
lot of my life I feel like
um uh I'm sort of the last person to
discover something you know like you
know
the house could be on fire and I'm sort
of the last one to figure that out or
something you know so I mean yeah I
think there's uh I think I have sort of
a sort of delayed reaction to things and
yes I think um
um I think Tanya is is uh started out
you know for especially first uh White
Lotus one and they're very naive and I
think um I think I my parents were sort
of naive wonderful people that never
thought there was any Badness and you
know anything bad in the world and I
sort of feel like I inherited their
naivete
and um
I'm just glad I lived to this moment now
where I'm
smarter a little bit smarter
thank you thank you
[Music]